problema número 214 de 50 investigadores
40% se asignarán al equipo y el 60 por
ciento se asignará al equipo b sin
embargo el 70% de los investigadores
prefieren el equipo a y 30% prefieren el
equipo ver cuál es el menor número de
investigadores que no serán asignados al
equipo que prefieren como siempre vamos
a anotar los datos el equipo a va a
tener el 40 por ciento de mis 50
investigadores y el equipo b va a tener
pues el restante que son el 60 por
ciento de estos mismos 50 investigadores
y nos dicen que el 70 por ciento de
estos mismos investigadores el 0.7 de 50
prefieren el equipo a
prefiere
y obviamente el restante que es el 30
por ciento de estos mismos 50 prefieren
al equipo b ave prefiere bueno pues
vamos a poner números el 40 por ciento
de 50 es 20 el 60 por ciento de 50 puede
ser 30 el 70 por ciento de 50 va a ser
igual a 35 este es 35 y aquí obviamente
el resto de los 50 van a ser 15 ese es
el caso en el que la mayoría obtiene lo
que quiere la mejor situación sería que
de los 35 que prefieren aa de estos de
aquí de a
35 que lo prefieren pues en verdad vayan
al equipo a equipo a que son 20 los que
pueden estar en este equipo que son 20
de estos 35 20 llegan al equipo a que
quieren y pues los demás pues van al
equipo ve que como que no es su
preferido entonces pues bueno son 15 que
no van a estar tan contentos y de los 15
que prefieren a ver que aquí son 15 que
prefieren este equipo pues vamos a poner
a todos en el ve aquí si nos caben
equipo ven que es el que quieren van
todos los 15 y aquí pues nadie va al
equipo a el mejor caso es que estos 15
que prefieren a ver pues vaya nave
entrenada de ese grupo que quieran y la
mayor parte de los que prefieren a
también vayan a entonces solamente nos
quedan así como que en la mínima
cantidad de los que no serán asignados
al equipo que prefieren pues serán estos
15 que serán asignados al equipo y esta
es mi opción a siguiente problema
problema número 215 si ms el promedio de
los 10 primeros múltiplos de 5 y m es la
mediana de lo mismo cuál es el valor de
m - m
vamos a ver cuáles son los múltiplos de
5 los primeros 10 5 10 15
20 25
y ahorita van a ver por qué voy a
acomodar los de esta manera ahora sigue
35 40
45 y 50 los acomodo de esta manera
porque me están pidiendo el promedio de
estos 10 números pero si se fijan si yo
sumo
550 55 61 10 más 45 a 55 y sumó 15 más
40 también me da 55 todos estos pares a
sumar se quedan 55 si yo saco el
promedio de estos dos va a ser igual a
27.5 y es la misma cantidad que tengo en
esto por lo que el promedio de todo esto
la m minúscula va a ser igual a
27.5 si no me creen hagan la cuenta hay
varias maneras de calcularlo si la suma
de cada renglón como les comentaba es 55
y este se multiplica por 5 55 por 5 nos
va a dar 275 y este 275 se divide entre
los 10 números que estamos usando de
manera que nos va a quedar el promedio
de 27.5 esta es una forma rápida de
calcular el promedio de los primeros 10
múltiplos de 5 y ahora quieren conocer
la mediana de esto recordemos que la
mediana es el número que está en medio
de un conjunto y aquí están los dos
números que están en medio y tengo que
promediar lo para encontrar la mediana y
ya lo adivinaron el promedio es 27.5 así
que mi mediana mi mayúscula también va a
ser igual a
27.5 por lo que mi operación de m
mayúscula - m minúscula va a ser igual a
27.5 menos 27.5 que va a ser igual a
cero y esta es mi opción b siguiente
problema problema número 206 si m es
mayor que 0 y x es igual a m entre 100
porque en términos de m qué porcentaje
es de x bueno vamos a multiplicar ambos
lados de esta ecuación por 100 entre m
va a ser 100 entre m por equis igual a
jeff y esto lo quiero escribir como un
porcentaje voy a reacomodar lo de manera
que se vea que es igual a 100 entre m
por equis quiero escribir como
porcentaje todo esto así como está nos
va a dar un número decimal para dejarlo
con un porcentaje lo tengo que
multiplicar por 100 por ejemplo no sé si
estos 100 entre m fuera igual a punto 2
al multiplicarlo por 100 quedaría 20%
así que para expresar esto como un
porcentaje voy a multiplicar esto por
100 que es igual a 10.000 entre m y esto
va a ser por ciento que es mi opción
siguiente problema número 217 cierta
clase tiene 1000 estudiantes y otra
clase más avanzada tiene 800 estudiantes
entre estos estudiantes hay 60 pares de
hermanos cada par tiene un hermano en la
clase 1 y otro hermano en la clase 2 si
se elige aleatoriamente una estudiante
de cada clase cuál es la probabilidad de
que los dos estudiantes seleccionados
sean hermanos como siempre vamos a
anotar nuestros datos la clase 1 tiene
1000 alumnos
la clase 2 tiene 800 800 y nos dicen que
hay 60 pares
de hermanos
y de estos 60 pares uno va a estar en la
clase uno y otro hermano va a estar en
la clase 2 muy bien digamos que primero
seleccionó un estudiante cuántos
estudiantes que tienen hermanos en otra
clase van a estar en c-1 aquí voy a
tener 60 estudiantes porque son 60 pares
aquí va a haber 60 estudiantes que
tienen hermanos en c2 y estos obviamente
tienen también 60 hermanos que están en
c-1 digamos que primero selecciona un
estudiante de c-1 qué probabilidad hay
de que éste sea de los que tienen
hermanos así que con hermanos de hecho
es con hermano es un hermano la
probabilidad de que se elija a alguien
que tiene un hermano es de 60 entre 1000
el número de estudiantes que tienen
hermanos entre el total de los
estudiantes de esta clase uno esto para
simplificarlo es igual a 3 entre 50 si
ya encontramos de esta clase 1 cuál es
la probabilidad de que justamente su
hermano sea seleccionado en la clase 2
bueno pues tendremos que seleccionar
justamente a una persona de toda la
clase 2 que va a ser el hermano de éste
que ya seleccionamos así que es esta
probabilidad
multiplicada por uno entre 800
una persona de los 800 que hay en
nuestra clase 2 y hacemos la
multiplicación para obtener la
probabilidad conjunta que es igual a 3
entre 8 por 540
40.000 que es nuestra opción
y con eso terminamos los problemas de
este vídeo y nos vemos en el siguiente